it's the holiday
REM think I only want you my missile toe
I'm might change a contact has a huge
pole you said you like my stocking
better on the floor boy I've been a bad
girl I guess I'm getting cold let me
come warm you up even out in the snow B
my tongue goes num sounds like ho ho ho
I don't want say no underneath this tree
it's a little car Ro it's about you and
me you're my wor list looking at you got
me thinking Christmas snowflakes in my
stomach when we're kissing and when you
coming down the chimney all feel so good
I need a your
tick you'll be standing closing I'll be
misses I'll take you through a r
beixing i don't even know I'm taking
Christmas I'm talking I'm talking I'm
talking decking all the HS I'm talking
spiking egg I'm talking opposite small
I'm talking bigballs you got a newy for
me I'm out here triming the tree I caugh
that holiday GLE my true love gave it to
me come warm you up even in the sow my
tongue go sounds like ho ho
ho underneath this old tree's a little
car Road it's about you and me my wish
list looking at you got me thinking
Christmas snowflakes in my stomach when
we're kissing and when you coming down
the chimney oh it feel so good I need
STI you'll be S CL and I'll be misses
I'll take you for a r you'll be a
big I don't even know I'm talking
Christmas I'm talking I'm talking I'm
talking I'm talking
[Music]
talking I'm
talking I'm talking I'm
talking look at all those presents
that's a big Sack Boy that package is
too big to Gift Rap woke up this morning
thought I'd write a Chris smash how
quickly can you build a snowman think
fast
[Music]
hey there friends I hope you enjoyed
that my final Ultra poy flow session of
2024 up by the Capitol building
uh if you are interested in grabbing a
set of those orb poy Pros that I was
using in this video you can do so at a
discount if you use the promo code Drex
factor with a zero instead of an o a
checkout you can get 10% off on the LED
poy of your choice and there's just a
few days left to make that happen before
the holidays hits so maybe uh this will
be a good opportunity to make that
happen uh real quickly a huge thank you
to ultra PO for sponsoring this video
and making it possible for me to get out
and flow in and around
DC speaking of thank yous I owe some
thank yous to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys pyro teror light toys
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links I
have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the non-b
buus friend of the channel That is Becca
Becken thank you so much for supporting
my channel my work and my mission
finally I would be remiss if I didn't
point out that this video and all the
videos on this channel would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd love to
give a huge shout out to my flow patrons
who are listed on screen right now thank
you y all rock if you are not currently
a patreon supporter but you'd like to
become one best way to do that is head
on over to patreon at patreon.com
drexfactor Po and sign up there you can
get a whole host of awesome rewards but
better than that you'll be supporting me
in my mission to bring po spinning and
flow Arts to the whole wide world so go
check that out please and thank you and
if you'd like to see more of the flow
sessions I've done over the years I will
go ahead and include a link to those
videos uh up on screen as well as down
in the description happy holidays
friends I hope you enjoy the end of your
Year and a happy New Year to you as well
take care now and I'll see you in 2025
peace